and you're watching book tv on c-span 2
live coverage of the miami book fair
charlie sykes who you just heard will be
joining us a little bit later and you'll
have the chance to talk with him in
about 15 minutes or so cnn's van jones
will be talking about his new book so
that's coming up
in the meantime we are set up in the
center of the festival with a book tv
call in set
and we're pleased to be joined by
author and journalist jefferson morley
his most recent book is called the ghost
the secret life of cia spymaster james
jesus angleton
who was
mr angleton mr morley james angleton
would be born in 1917 he'd be 100 years
old this year he was a yale educated spy
and one of really the founding
personalities of the cia one of the most
powerful men in the cia from its
founding in 1947
until his forest retirement in 1974. so
really a founding father of of us
counterintelligence what type of issues
and areas did he work on
angleton used his position as chief of
counter intelligence staff to really
create a kind of cia within the cia and
so he he dabbled everywhere uh he was
very influential in u.s policy towards
israel
created programs of mass surveillance
opening the mail of of of americans um
involved in the uh
domestic surveillance schemes of the
nixon white house for example um
involved in the early days of the mk
ultra mind experiment program a story i
tell in the ghost this was a man who
made his influence felt everywhere very
involved in u.s policy towards cuba
so this position he a lot of cia
officers rise through a geographical
directorate you know division within the
cia angleton was kept had his fingers in
many many things was he a well-known
personality during the years he was
active no he was not in fact there's
stories that that
i one story that i heard one man worked
for him for four years and never knew
who he was he was very secretive in his
ways even within the cia
one of the underlying themes of your
book is the importance of bureaucratic
infighting that comes up again and again
yes angleton is a master of that as an
administrator he's kind of lousy he
doesn't deal well with his subordinates
imagine having somebody work for you for
four years and doesn't know who you are
but in a one-to-one meeting angleton was
extremely intelligent and his
presentations were very compelling he
cultivated alan dulles
richard helms cia directors and so he
was able to maintain his position even
when he came in for a lot of criticism
from his other colleagues in the cia so
jefferson morley
if you survive in the cia at that level
from 47 to 75 we often think about j
edgar hoover over at the fbi surviving
that many presidents
did he get close to the presidents as
well or was he did he have dirt on
people what was a he was like j edgar
hoover and he was he was a close
collaborator with hoover for for many
years hoover didn't like the cia at all
but he did come to trust angleton
because angleton supplied him with that
kind of secret information and and both
hoover and angleton were masters at
using secrets to leverage their power so
yes angleton did collect information
the president and the presidents he was
probably closest to president nixon
nixon was the man who appealed to him
most he thought eisenhower may be a bit
stodgy jfk a bit weak lbj a bit crude
nixon for angleton was was the best
prepared president so he liked nixon a
lot and it's it's telling that you know
they both fell
at the same time and for the same reason
because they were spying on their
enemies uh they were obsessive about
secrecy nixon resigns in august of 1974
and angleton is fired in december of
1974. kind of the last chapter of
watergate
is there a room at the cia named after
mr angleton no you know within the cia
angleton is not in in good standing then
when this
they sent people agents back to review
what what had this man done because it
was so secretive the cia themselves
didn't know
and the internal consensus of the cia on
angleton is negative that he made a lot
of mistakes and he and his actions
harmed the agency so
he has not honored
that much within the agency
you say in the book the ghost that his
legacy is the mass surveillance of
americas of americans yeah
you know
today we have these powerful systems of
mass surveillance that we've learned
where the nsa can pick up on your email
and your telephone calls angleton
pioneered an early version of that which
was the opening of the mail of americans
overseas mail
he picked up this program in 1955 it was
very small
uh it was opening 100 200 letters a year
within a few years he was opening 10 000
letters a year and on the barest of
authority there was really no legal
justification there was no warrant there
was no probable cause for opening
people's mail uh and he he ran this
program from 50 late 50s to
the early 70s opening 10 000 letters a
year copying them indexing the names
so this really was america's first mass
surveillance program so you can see it
as the
as the progenitor of the of the of the
systems that we have today
he used the same justification for these
systems
that we hear today from the nsa and the
cia
another line from the book is that mr
angleton was not surprised
when lee harvey oswald shot jfk
well he knew he might have been
surprised when he shot him but he knew
very well who lee harvey oswald was and
one of the most distinctive things but
one of the most important pieces of the
book is that angleton put oswald under
close monitoring in november 1959 and
for the next four years wherever oswald
went angleton was informed in detail
about what he was doing who he was in
touch with his politics his personal
life his foreign travels so
the story that was fed to the american
people after the assassination that this
this guy came out of nowhere and shot
the president that was a cover story to
protect angleton
oswald had been monitored for four years
before november 22 1963. did the cia
know he was in dallas in november of 63.
a week before
the assassination on november 15 1963
angleton's top aide signs for an fbi
report and we have the routing slip jane
roman his liaison officer received the
report and in that report the new
orleans fbi office reported that oswald
had returned from mexico city and was
living in the dallas area so i believe
that angleton read that report he was a
voracious consumer of intelligence
i believe that angleton knew oswald was
in dallas a week before the
assassination now mr morley you've been
a reporter for 30 some years did you
just go out to the cia and go through
their archives to find this information
no i asked them for an interview
and and
not surprisingly they turned me down i
got this book from interviews with
retired cia people declassified cia
records and archival material at the lbj
library the gerald ford library the jfk
library as well as different collections
at stanford yale and uh boston
university so a lot this was kind of an
investigative biography
if the cia
documents were available would this be a
different book or
absolutely there's a secret study of of
angleton's tenure as chief of the
counterintelligence staff it's 12
volumes each volume is three to four
hundred pages and that study
which encompasses angleton's entire
career is totally classified so
the the the full story of james angleton
is still classified this as i say in the
beginning of the book this is the story
as best it can be told so far
if americans are suspicious about a
shadow
government
running this country
your book gives a little bit of support
to that doesn't it well you know when i
started this book nobody talked about
the deep state that was an unknown
phrase two years later the president of
the united states believes in it and
it's in headlines all the time so this
suspicion is very deep so i i wasn't
going to look for the deep state but if
you look at angleton's career you see
the power that somebody can
accumulate
operating within these secret agencies
and it does lend credence to these fears
that people are secretly manipulating
our political system from these
positions of secrecy angleton certainly
did
what do we not know about him in his or
what what should we know about his
personal life where did he live in
washington who were his friends
engleton was a very um attractive man
personally and people really
you know people really believed in him
um he was a father of three he lived
very modestly in uh in arlington
virginia off of glebe road um his his
wife came from a very wealthy family but
there was nothing ostentatious about him
he was really an intellectual he he
cared about books and travel
he was at the end of his career an
alcoholic and that tended to isolate him
and and it also made his thinking rigid
and this is what led to his downfall he
lost allies within the cia by the early
1970s but you know what even when i
didn't like him he was a very
he was never an uninteresting man he was
a very complex
character and he was always interesting
to try and figure out
how he how he was thinking and how he
made his way
he was in his office until 1975. have
you talked with people who knew him well
yes i did um i talked with a man named
ephraim halevi who was the
uh eventually became the chief of the
mossad
and um halevi knew angleton from when
angleton would go to israel which he did
quite frequently
and halevi was a junior officer who was
you know carrying his briefcase and
driving the car
um but halevi knew him quite well i
talked with a man named peter sischel
who was a
cia officer who worked with him in the
1950s
i talked with jane roman who was his
aide bill hood was another man who
worked for him who i interviewed so
these retired cia people
some of whom are now dead
you know provided this insight into what
was the man like in his work
jefferson morley spent many years at the
washington post
and uh do you write for them anymore
uh occasionally and do you have a piece
coming up yes i'm going to write about
the jfk files in the washington post the
ones that were just recently released
yeah we're trying to go through them and
figure out what's new and significant
and i have some ideas towards that end
have you found and you're going through
these what 28 000 pages or files
have you found some new material
yeah there are things that are new it's
a little bit confusing because some of
this stuff has been made public before
and people who come to the subject for
the first time think oh wow look at this
those of us who've been
involved in this you know know that
that's not true but so far there have
been some interesting things but
remember the cia knows what's in there
so they're not going to release the good
stuff first they're going to release the
good stuff last so we are still waiting
for the most important material to be
released the author is jefferson morley
the book the ghost the secret life of
cia spymaster
james jesus angleton
book tv is live in miami for the miami
book fair and coming up next is cnn's
van jones his new book is called beyond
the messy truth he's going to be talking
about that afterwards we're going to
show you a little bit of the book
signing that mr jones is doing and then
we want to hear your reaction to what he
has to say in his presentation so it's
your chance to talk about what you heard
and that's what's coming up several more
hours live
go to our website booktv.org to see the
full schedule and beginning in just a
moment van jones
you